there and speaking of people that did
well in this event second place also
went to maxima cher lagrave fresh off
his win on the sink field cup he's here
with maurice
indeed with a big comeback ferocious
come back to
come in thai for second maxime
this tournament seemed like it wasn't
really yours to grab and then you played
yourself into it how do you feel about
your overall performance
i feel i've played some interesting 960
games and
it didn't always go the way i wanted
sometimes i took maybe a bit too many
risks but uh
in general i was happy with you know the
interesting ideas we got and
you know the fresh play
so
it's you know a good uh
refreshment for for the brain do you
feel like there should be more of these
events you'd like to see something more
like this somewhere along the calendar
as you guys got to show your creativity
in all those games for sure like not as
a main thing but uh
yeah a couple times a year would be nice
yeah i mean then you know it's not
something we should exhaust completely
like by force feeding
this thing also
because it's not
easy for the audience to comprehend so
you know there's
maybe a way also to
helps the audience make feel more feel
more at home when they have to analyze
these crazy positions that even we have
no clue about basically when i play
against the stock fishing chest 960 i
lose in 15 moves in every game so
you know
that means that you know
moves are difficult to find i mean you
know chess actual chess here it took a
long time to you know
get created and uh
for sure there's a lot for us to learn a
lot for
for the audience but uh
you know
make it uh user friendly
should be the way to go i think
you
defeated gary in the last round but he
had an amazing result overall
nevertheless
your feelings about him showing that he
can still get it done i mean i knew that
you know
gary's performance in croatia was
a fluke in a way and i knew that
you can still play amazing chess and uh
he got to show a lot of interesting
ideas a lot of great games i think he
for instance his game against sam
shantland it was just
yeah
an obliteration if i
if i may say and uh
yeah
i knew that he was going to be a tough
opponent and i'm happy that he showed
you know the doubters
that he could still play
great and you know
maybe he has a few more tournaments in
him
indeed you have been in st louis for
quite some time actually before the
rapid and blitz even which you didn't
even play in you won the sing field cup
you came entire for second here how do
you feel about your summer here in the
capital chess in the u.s
it was definitely a great summer for me
and
you know in general i've played much
better
since
since july and croatia and i've done the
rest of the year so i'm hoping to
you know keep on that path and right now
of course i'm looking forward to come
back to france get some deserved rest
and you know
see the cities that i love so much and i
haven't had the chance to be in for for
a few months now i'm sure france is
waiting for you as well congratulations
on your performance and have a good trip
back thank you maurice